[Music]
little disclaimer you know i love a good
disclaimer there may be a brag or two in
this little opening here
brag number one over the years i've been
gifted watches here's the thing and this
is to anyone who has maybe sent me a
watch over the years first of all you
should know that the main thing is i
don't wear watches and i was recently
given a watch probably my favorite one
i've been given from uh grillo's pickles
one of my favorite pickle companies
we've talked about on the show and um so
i apologize directly to them because i
will not be wearing the watch it's a
little
i love i really like the watch it's got
their little logo on it they're grillo
it's nothing personal not at all i just
don't like wearing watches um but thank
you for it and uh i mean i guess to make
up for we've given them a nice shout out
and i don't want to speak for you but
much more importantly than their watch
their pickles are incredible incredible
and you continue to eat them so thanks
grillos thanks grills and keep making
those great pickles
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short and i
am your watchlist host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my
recently
contemplating getting a watch co-host
brother christian i was recently
contemplating that yeah weren't you just
saying you you might get what you you
could be a watch guy
no i think i was saying i wish i could
be a watcher oh oh and if i had more
confidence in
for among other things my wrists or
wrists just one wrist it requires
confidence in i probably would wear a
watch i like the idea of
wearing a watch because i think it looks
good i think it's nice to not have to
look at your phone to know what time it
is that's what i thought you were saying
you wanted to learn the phone i do want
it the problem is my body doesn't
support watches i think you have to get
past that first of all i'll tell you why
let me be a little more specific yeah
i've always been a bit insecure about
the thinness i know we have risks we
have i guess you don't bother to be
insecure but the thing is
but over the years as i've gotten older
i've i've gotten over that okay to the
point where i pretty much never think
about this yeah you never mention that
but here's what i have and here's a
problem i have a bone that protrudes
right underneath
my hand at the top of my wrist
you do too yeah um but mine is more
pronounced and it's like a little ball
of bone
that it makes wearing a watch pretty
uncomfortable yeah i bet unless unless
here's the other option i wear it below
the bone why don't you do that it looks
goofy it does yeah it's too far down you
want it right underneath the hand it
looks like you're you have a like flesh
sleeve exposed i've thought about this
quite a bit yeah i'm my wrist does not
support a watch you also have and this
shouldn't be a reason this should be a
good reason they're hairy their hair
yeah i always forget you're very rich
that's not a reason not to wear a watch
though as far as i'm concerned it's the
it's this bone uh yeah i remember
working when i was like 17 or 18
working at a coffee shop and
shout out to cafeteria you should have
something that's no longer a great place
cafe taza yeah if you know you know
robert
and a customer came in one day and i was
chatting with him while making his drink
and his daughter who must have been like
maybe four or three or four
she kept like
i saw her eyes like fix on my wrists
and she
and she said to her dad she said what is
that and she pointed to me no i swear to
god and uh
obviously i've never forgotten that
turns out she was pointing at my weird
wrist yeah that's not that i'm looking
at it you have to look at it closely
also i was younger maybe it was more
pronounced
and i remember being like oh yeah i
guess my wrist is just uh i got this
bump here weird but it made me so
insecure that this little kid isn't
pointing something out like isn't that
funny how that can alter it i've never
forgotten about it it can alter the not
the course of your life but alter your
behavior that a little like comment from
somebody yes
it's also like when you're 17 years old
now you're feeling pretty insecure about
your body oh my man my wrists at the
time i know such a source of insecurity
a lot of my appearance was a source of
insecurity right i used to look at my
profile in the mirror and think like god
that is
i can't believe i look like that you
want your chin to be bigger right shin
the jaw like you know you like
the cool kids the cool and they're all
kind of better proportioned anyway it
all worked out it worked out and um but
you know it's over the i can't tell you
how many times wardrobe people it
happened recently with um
if i wear a watch which i often do in
movies because i play like
like nerds and guys who have their stuff
together and
like i don't have and so they'll fit me
with a watch and now i just say i can't
i i can't do it but there were so many
times where they'd be like huh i say i
don't know my wrists are pretty thin i
don't know if you that'll fit no no no
this is a this is a little watch that's
meant for smaller brazilian still on the
titanic or the amount of times that's
happening more embarrassing they have to
punch we have dainty wrists so what's so
wide who cares why are we talking about
right because we're not watch it's made
us for whatever reason my thing with
time your thing with the wrist it's made
us not watch we've it's prevented us
from being watchmen i'm not a watchman
why are we talking who else is a
watchman well let's see our guest today
sure is
he was in one of my favorite superhero
movies uh we've talked about on the show
because we've had other watchmen on the
show but the watchmen that we watch man
that we have today
watch person
is
patrick wilson yes the from watchmen the
watchman the movie that has nothing to
do with wearing watches
oh but it was dry but it's got to do
with time that's true but it was
directed by friend of the show zach
spider also starring friend of the show
billy crudup and friend of the show male
and actor we have had a lot of watch a
lot of watch people on the show um
but patrick wilson is not just a
watchman no he's in he's also probably
if i have to guess never been insecure
about his wrists oh i doubt it but but
we do talk about him again like a theme
on the show we explore these people who
you would think never would have
insecurities certainly about his
appearance um
he he touches on that a little bit um
and you know i'm sure it was minimal
compared to what we went through in high
school but um
he is just such a he's a somebody i've
known for a while always such an affable
uh
positive person and funny smart he's
great great theater actor tony award
nominated actor yeah he was in um angels
in america he's done so much great
theater
he's an aquaman yeah he's is he jason
he's the dad the dad
you don't bother not have seen aquaman
but but now
he's in a movie called moonfall he's a
moon man he's a moon man he's an
astronaut yeah in moonfall directed by
the great roland emmerich yes and also
co-starring the great halle berry
hopefully future guests oh yeah future
friend sorry yeah friend of the show
hopefully and um uh who's in those
commercials with friend of the show uh
jb's move yeah uh anyways
i know this is such an arrogant opening
uh but anyway patrick's uh great you're
about to hear how how uh funny and uh
bright and thoughtful he is we talk
about there's a little bit of acting
inside acting talk which uh if you're
into that um he's he's just such a good
idea you forget what a good oh he's also
in those great uh horror movies the
inspiration oh controversy yeah can't
believe that's maybe
kind of most known for right yeah i
think people yeah those movies are huge
so let's get into it with um my old
friend and uh the very talented funny
very affable punk patrick wilson
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
who's on your lap uh a
furry little golden this is eddie he is
a uh
he is a uh uh a cavapoo
cava
cava is kev
spring uh cavalier chicken
charles spanner yep yep mixed with a
with a poo just
defecate a lot
um yeah so he's basically a therapy dog
for one of the other dogs i have julia
but he ends up being funny he ends up
being my therapy dog and during every
zoo like he literally
he's got to be here or else
patrick's patrick's just got this
beautiful fluffy dog on his i can only
see the top of it on his lap there he is
say hi
buddy he's like reluctantly looking at
me um
that's really that's really cute so he's
your therapy dog and for the other dog
why are your other dogs really like high
um high energy one is one has really bad
like anxiety problems just feels so bad
she's she's not uh not working with a
full deck
yeah i my parents have one named pearl a
rescue dog from l.a who over the pearl a
little like black probably a little type
of poodle chihuahua mix or something but
um is constantly she's so attached to my
father that
whenever he leaves her site um
she or or like vicinity she just cries
constantly so sad
and it's the point where they've they're
so accustomed to it that they my parents
that they just drown out that they're i
think it's so normalized that like
you know i'll be talking to him for a
couple of minutes and it's this constant
din of like
and if
if she were a human it would be like i
need you
you know
and he's just like what i said what
doesn't that drive you nuts and i can
see him tune back into it so he'll go
like uh oh yeah that i mean like it's
just right it's like it's like parents
with screaming kids you just get used to
it like so i don't notice it until a
friend comes over it's like dude your
three-year-old has been screaming for 20
minutes like
oh no that happened
yeah
what else yeah i thought something's
wrong wait wait
it's just this then in those moments
patrick because you have a bunch of
this silence become kind of weird
it's very strange yeah when the kids go
to school it's just like
you know oh yeah yeah it's like
tumbleweeds yeah
that's funny you uh how many kids do you
have though 17. uh oh that okay last
time was fourteen i have two boys yeah
twelve and three two okay yeah twelve
and 15.
yeah oh i don't know why i thought it
was more well we because we often travel
in a pack we had nine people stay in my
house for about eight months during the
pandemic i had dad's
little sister veronica and her family
and she was actually
she she was pregnant and then gave birth
not at home but uh but gave birth at
that hospital but our nine became ten so
we had
veronica did you mean yes veronica gave
birth yeah so we had we had from a
newborn to my mother-in-law and uh you
know dogs and cousins here for for a
good from
about
actually even before new york shut down
because my brother-in-law works in
finance and he was like listen they're
gonna shut new york down you think we
could come stay with you for like two
weeks and i was like sure man
yeah yeah why not literally two weeks
tops i'm sure literally nine
uh about eight months later yeah it was
all good it was great
oh wow yeah
i know it must be like the mixed bag of
like well you get to be around family
but then it's like that's a lot of
family for a long extended period it was
but you know
it was and it's easy to make jokes about
it but but to be fair it was um it was
awesome i mean everybody actually got
along and we i think we would have all
gone a little batty if it were just our
little pods so we were just like i bet
we just kind of had to deal with it it's
like living on a commute yeah
yeah yeah a very
like gorgeous commune i didn't know
there was another
three of them three girls yeah yes okay
um
that's funny and and and your dog's name
is what again this is eddie van wilson
eddie wilson why why
oh van halen i'm a huge van halen fan
and um but i i didn't name it but my kid
then when eddie
when the real eddie uh passed away last
year it was like right around the same
time as we're getting the dogs and mike
and we were going through all these
names like
grover elmo yeah cheese whiz you know
just something sort of random
and then my kids where kids were like
we want to name them eddie van wilson
for you because they knew i was i was
legit i was legitimately
sad that that uh yeah you know as we all
as we all do no matter like you know we
see
somebody that um you know regardless of
if you know them or not when they when
they sort of define a portion of your
youth right and they're gone oh my gosh
especially especially with rock stars
because then you feel like
right i'm never
like i'm never going to see them again
that's crazy yes yeah well and there's
something so alive their lives are so
kind of heightened and they're larger
than life and so for that life then to
be
absent to be non-existent yeah it's
extra you got to do um
it's extra strange i think that they're
just such
present um
a really sweet thing and also i'm sure
eddie is happy to not be called cheese
whiz he must be like
he doesn't care thank god he's a dog
he oh right he's a dog i don't know if
we mentioned that actually
that the living thing on your lap
throughout the interview
you yourself um
you know this we shot that movie in
tampa right before the pandemic around
the time and um
you know we were we i've been talking to
you about doing something like a cameo
or whatever which by the way i wish you
had done because it was uh not to it was
general sherman it was a general a civil
war general who um
is kind of an unsavory figure in history
but he it was played by
all we needed was somebody who looked
like a distinguished
general and i love our dp nick shout out
to nick margulis but he
is quite he'll
he'll admit this he's sure he's very
she's like five foot three right and but
he is bearded which is why we picked him
he has a nice natural and on the day
that we did it and it was judy greer was
the actress he was playing the opposite
i love her having to oh yeah she was she
we made the mistake of being like i
think we might be able to get patrick
wilson and she got very excited
she got very excited
and then when it came time she was like
oh so patrick's not doing it who's doing
it oh you're like diminutive dp
this is who looks like i love nick but
he looks like a kid who was able to grow
a beard
and so we had to put him on apple boxes
and it was it's clear he's on apple
boxes you know like whatever it's that's
to me in a way that's the funniest part
of the movie and she has to be looking
down on her but um so that was a
disappointment for judy if you ever run
into her i will tell her how was your
experience in tampa
well it's funny because patrick
everywhere we went everyone had a story
about
a wilson whether it's your parents your
father who you know acts a lot and your
brother is a newscaster there but you
are the most buzzed about and it's
always glowing it was never like those
wilson's oh yeah no no it was always
like well you know i ran into
i once babysat the wilsons right
you know what some connection um do you
i and and you seem like you really love
it it holds a special place in your
heart but like it's you are beloved
there uh what what was it like growing
up there as the
kennedys
without without yeah in a good way yes i
know i wasn't going to make a kennedy
joke um yeah yeah no i
it i mean the easy answer is it was it
was uh
it was awesome it was um
what's interesting to me is i still it
holds such a special place in my heart
also because my we just moved my parents
out of the house we grew up in like
during the pandemic like
so that was really uh that was a that
was strange to say at least because i've
got cousins down there and a lot we've
been down there
since 82 we moved there so wow i mean
really i spent the majority of my
youth there
which ended up
really only being about ten years but it
was just that
fourth grade formative time you know
what i mean so because i moved away and
went to college and moved to new york so
i haven't really lived there since 91
but i keep going
you know obviously i go back and now i
go back with my brothers because as you
mentioned one brother is a tv anchor and
he took over from my dad who was the
anchor down there for like you know 40
50 years um wow
and then my other brother runs a media
company advertising and um and he's also
an actor he's been in a couple moves
with me um yeah he um
and we now we do these concerts back to
our van halen thing we do
we're basically a glorified cover band
but we
i now go down it gives me a reason other
than just to see family but we try to
schedule like one event every year where
we can we do it as a fundraiser um oh
that's right yeah so we do that
and cover of course we couldn't do it
but we just announced our show that
we're gonna do in saint pete
um at an outdoor venue that i used to
see concerts at all the time around uh
memorial day sunday of the month oh cool
yeah
oh that's that's funny okay uh yeah
what's the venue just because we we
might have been there we shot all right
it's in st pete it's called uh janus
landing janice live is the venue it's
outdoors it yes yeah
it was shot there it's near pelican pub
right pelican pub maybe i mean dude
those bars
they changed i know it's it's connected
to club detroit there's an entrance yes
it's yes it's it's in a a very under
it's on florida like it's it's a
courtyard it's a glorified yeah yes and
there's a big there's a big landing on
top right where you can yes we shot that
oh that's awesome but when you were down
there were you i imagined that you were
it's funny you're such an interesting
person to me because you look like you
would have been the quarterback of the
football team and they got this
stereotype you're like you have the
looks of somebody who would have
succeeded in a way in high school and
then everything would have been downhill
does that make sense like you might i
don't know if i'm articulating that
properly but you are you have a you but
you're like you everything
you should have peaked but you're still
peaking you're still on the ride but um
you you have a humility of somebody who
didn't i don't know how to say this i
mean it might be my own prejudice but
who didn't have those looks that the
looks that you have what i i guess my
question is how did you maintain
a sense of humility looking the way you
do
and being talented and all that how um
how did your parents i mean was that
your parents who kept you kind of
grounded throughout adolescence
i mean
so much in there wow i know i know
that's a lot to unpack i'm basically
saying you're too happy to be nice no
thank you that's nice
um
uh
i
i don't know you know looks is a i mean
we all
i don't know i ha i always yeah i have
my
insecurities and tons of insecurities
about my looks so i but i never i never
like felt like oh my god i'm i'm ugly
but i also never felt like oh my god i'm
really like i'm really awesome like i
just
i don't i never operated like that and i
think i think honestly having not that
my parents ever had to like sit us down
or anything
but uh you know i'm one of three boys
like i said and my parents
they always lived very
modestly like what you did
what you did for a career
didn't define you like my dad is still
huh my dad is still this
sweet salt of the earth dude from big
stone gap virginia like from appalachia
likes like
and even though he was a tv anchor which
in the 70s and 80s and even in the 90s
sort of pre-internet i mean your local
anchor was like yeah if you saw ron
bergeron out it was ron burgundy without
the scotch basically it was like you
know you you
so i grew up
with people responding to him
and i always thought how he was just so
nice and chill and yet he was always uh
you know if you saw him on the weekend
he was in like you know paint splattered
pants and you wearing dress socks up to
you know just like he he never we didn't
live in the i mean he certainly did well
but i never knew anything about their
money never knew anything about their
politics i knew nothing i knew nothing
we just lived in and basically a golden
girls i mean a beautiful house but not i
mean i went to a private school with a
lot of people who had a lot of money in
the
gorgeous homes and
and i didn't live like that and i think
and my parents never aspired to to do
that even if they had money yes you know
what i'm saying so so we were never led
by success was not what
you um it wasn't aspirational yeah it
was like a stat it wasn't a measure of a
person it wasn't it was connected
so i never looked at a career like
anything other than just wanting it to
be versatile and want to be different as
a kid though i wonder i remember the
first time somebody was an adult was
impressed or
acted different around a celebrity
around another adult it was um
when jason robards came into our pizza
place when i was a kid he lived nearby
and you know a kid doesn't know who
jason roberts is but i
knew the name only because people acted
different once he walked in and so i
remember taking note of that and being
struck by it and um
and and uh but
it's an experience you must have had
with your father what
what did you how did that feel when
people gave your father status in front
of you
um my dad always tried to make people he
always did all the talking because
people just
would sort of either not know what to
say or they would they would act like
they do when they see somebody on tv
that is on tv every night like they know
him so i'm very familiar i got used to
my dad someone going hey john how you
doing hey you know i want to ask you you
know you guys said this was going to
happen then he yeah all right he'd talk
and then he'd leave and i would say and
i would say daddy who was that he'd go i
have no idea
and and it was less about his memory but
more about just like people think they
know me
they they may
but either way you just got to be nice
to everybody and just half of it yeah
that's so funny well that makes sense
patrick you are one of the nicest i am
and i so i imagine then
acting with something that you
you're such a good actor so so talented
but so i imagine it was just something
that you
loved purely that would that the the
trappings of fame were never a
consideration right they weren't because
i couldn't even
fathom that like i don't know about you
i mean maybe growing up closer to like
new york you have a sense of like how
things really work right like the
business maybe no
well well well i don't uh no no in fact
if anything maybe the opposite only
because my mom was an actress oh i
didn't know that did you go to school
for it i know
yeah i went to i went to school no i did
a lot of theater in squad i dropped out
of college i went to vassar for two
years um and i know carnegie carnegie
mellon where you went is one of the best
where
i think i probably
would have liked to have gone had i
known
i i just didn't think that that was a
possibility for me yeah isn't that funny
like we all sort of manage our
we just don't know what possibilities
are and i had that experience the only
reason i knew about carnegie mellon so i
was in saint pete and when i was about
15 i went away to a pre-college program
at bu
with a friend of mine who dragged me
there just like hey do you want to go
it's like a six-week theater workshop
and i was like i like theater cool so i
went oh it was that casual you weren't
like it wasn't it was not in it
i
because i was in such a tiny private
school i i had done several shows and i
was like seymour and little shop and all
that stuff so so i knew i knew about
like but i wasn't the guy who was like
do you have this new sondheim recording
i was like i'm listening to like white
lion like you know van gaal crazy like
hair bands i'm not i don't know show
tunes um so but my oh he's getting up
are we okay
speaking he heard you heard his name
yeah
um uh he's really terrible he's super
cute like this i wish you were filmed
um so i
but that summer which i was uh 89
uh was when i i
was when i i i did something and it
i did like a monologue or a scene at uh
during that summer um
at this at but i
at boston and i got really emotional and
then i was like oh wait
oh that's hang on that's what acting is
not necessarily crying but like
oh i'm feeling emotion from the script
so it's my job to make an audience feel
that way and then i came back right and
i and i and i understand because i've as
i'm sure you have you talked to so many
young actors and even family members and
it's like you know if you don't have
that moment of like if you're not in it
for the right reasons it's such a oh man
it's such a slippery slope right so it's
so true yeah and my brother had gone to
florida state
in the in the
theater program but coming from a small
private school he
he did not have that summer experience
of being all day all night theater so it
was a major shock because i think he was
like i like theater i'm good at it but i
kind of want animal house and uh to go
to state games like he didn't understand
like if you go to florida state theater
and you're a bfa major like that's what
you're doing and so yeah but i
sort of through thespian society i don't
know if you guys had that at your school
like through the international thespian
society and i competed and i and i got
more focused so that i was like oh i
want that conservatory program and i
remember looking through like american
theater magazine or whatever those
magazines were because yeah internet
and you're like
you know juilliard carnegie mellon and i
was so scared of juilliard
because they didn't want to i didn't
want to go to new york it just seemed
like no i needed it it's also a scary
name it's just so like julia yeah
it's either that or jail yard it just
seemed like really like oh god um i got
so scared so then carnegie and cmu was
the next choice for me because i
literally wanted like
grass
and like a football team even though
they're division three and i never saw a
game i wanted i wanted i wanted to feel
like are there frat houses there again i
only went to like two frat parties but i
wanted coffee yeah
anyways yeah
that makes sense patrick it's funny at
the same moment i that same like lose
yourself in a scene moment with um
neil simon play blac uh biloxi blues
yeah played uh eugene when there's the
mo i remember there's this monologue
about how he got bullied basically in
the
uh and i just i remember coming off
stage and not no you know kids were
always like how's the audience yeah
who's out there were they laughing and i
couldn't res i couldn't answer i i i was
like you know i don't i i realized i
wasn't i had that great moment of
disconnect from
the audience or from whatever you know
uh whoever's around you um and it felt
it was exciting to feel like i had been
in inside of a character in telling a
story from like another person's point
of view it was it was uh thrilling but i
know that feeling it's it's addictive
too it's like
you want to keep exploring that
i agree i think because
it makes you and whatever your your your
your track ends up being
with pursuing acting you never forget
those moments because that's i'll forget
every single audience but i can remember
those times where you know i remember
the my senior year of doing like a of
high school and doing a a one-act play
and i had no business doing it it was uh
terence mcnally play years later when i
worked for terrence i told him he was
like why are you doing that one act when
you're 17. oh really oh funny yeah but i
remember someone else we lost recently
yeah i know i know um but i remember
just being affected by the words i think
that's a powerful thing for an actor and
i think if you don't have that
experience early on you may have a
different view of the business which is
fine totally
feasible like i just want to be a star
or whatever like okay good luck but i
think if you have something that starts
with something very personal like just
how you related to biloxi blues you're
like i want that again i don't what that
does to me
[Music]
curology we've been talking about both
of our skins our skins our skin both of
our faces christian and my face i don't
speak for his face but i can because
i've observed his face and i can tell
you that it's um it's looking a lot
fresher cleaner curology is a
game-changing custom skincare it's made
for you by a dermatology provider they
create a custom prescription cream for
your specific goals whether it's
tackling acne clogged pores skin texture
dark spots fine lines or
something else they tailor it to you you
start by taking a short online skin quiz
and uploading photos and if it's a good
fit they will ship you your formula
right to your door it even has your name
on the bottle you don't have to get lost
in the skin care aisle anymore or do all
that guesswork about what's going to
work for your skin curology takes the
pain out of finding the right products
by sending you a full dermatologist
designed routine a cleanser moisturizer
and a custom formula it's made for your
goals it really works get started with
curology just like i did with a free
30-day trial at
curology.com slash long just pay five
dollars for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash long to start your free
30-day trial cancel anytime prescription
is subject to consultation just check
them out at curology.com long and you
can start your free 30-day trial
who doesn't like flavors in their mouths
i have my own favorites
mango or
pasta flavor i mean there's so many to
choose from but now being flavorless is
a good thing caliper's dissolvable cbd
powder has absolutely no flavor and it's
more effective than cbd oils because
it's clinically proven to deliver 30
times more cbd in the first 30 minutes
than cbd oil when the alternative feels
like you're eating a handful of grass
flavorless is a no-brainer caliber cbd
packets are also carefully measured to
contain exactly 20 milligrams so you can
just put zero effort into figuring out
your dosage who wants to exert any
effort right before they go to sleep
because not stressing is kind of the
whole point caliper cbd is always thc
free because you want to feel better
without any trippy side effect feelings
and it's developed by food scientists
who rigorously test it for purity and
quality it's all natural it's vegan it's
non-gmo it's free of fillers added
chemicals artificial flavors flavorless
for say goodbye to flavor with caliper
cbd get 20 off your first order with
promo code long at try caliper dot com
slash long that's try caliper
dot com slash long try risk free for 30
days if you don't love it they'll just
give you full refund that's
tricaliper.com
long don't forget promo code long for 20
off your first order
hello hello
[Music]
but you must have been a good singer you
must have been a great singer in high
school is that where you discovered your
ability i was not a great singer i was
super musical and my mother was a choir
director and so i sang in church choir
the downside is i was total like
straight tone no vibrato not a but
the good side of that is
when i got to school i had never had a
proper voice lesson i had sung in choir
since i was like two so i developed very
naturally so i didn't get like a
like a vibrato like oh a guy can sing
until literally like junior year of
school and did you thrive in that
environment in carnegie mellon i mean
we're your teacher well you can i know
you're a humble person so this might be
hard to answer but were you
were you an impressive student i don't i
to be honest it's funny bring that up i
don't know
like if someone
listed like
who are the top actors in your class
like not musical theater actors i don't
i don't know if i'm
if i'm in that well it's hard to answer
yeah i don't know
like 25 years ago
yeah but i also know that but you did
but you found six out of carnegie mellon
i mean success came
relatively quickly i know it may have
felt longer but people say that to me
and i remember and i think well what are
you talking about it went like
a couple years and those years felt so
long that where things weren't happening
where i was waiting what was your first
gig
uh the first thing was galaxy quest
really i mean i did a pilot
i know
well i always say to people like i was
just talking to uh i was like talking to
like uh kevin you know people about
their first gig were like it could have
been anything i would have done right
you know nightmare on the street 12
it would have been anything um
and and it happened to be this like
really good thing but it was it was from
a pilot that didn't get picked up and
the casting director's sister was kept
it was one of those things where it was
like
that was the luck but it was like oh i
went in for everything i um
you know as i'm sure you did all the
cattle call everything uh everything yes
uh and and
was was yours would you was yours angels
in america was that like what yeah but
that was so late into my i mean i was
after oklahoma it was before oklahoma
but i mean i was close to 30 that by
that time i did angels yeah wow that's
the thing
i'm 48. when i got out of school i was
really on this
musical theater track
once i was in school
i did have this feeling of like
i think i'm gonna do movies in my 30s
huh when i got to new york there were
only a handful of guys that did look
like me
but could sing i mean a handful at an
equity call cheyenne jackson yeah he's
after me i mean there's like yeah yeah
you know it was like me and will chase
who still works all the time will's
awesome matt bogart you still work you
know there's a lot there's there's a lot
of musical theater guys in there that
were like yeah they were like guys like
we were guys you know but they're just
there just wasn't that so and i never
looked at musical theater different than
than doing like chekov it's like i get
the same out of it which is probably why
yeah i can value something like moonfall
or a horror movie or a little weird
indie or like
tomahawk because i i'm still using my
same skill set sometimes even harder
with that kind of script so for so i
figured you know what i'm going to do
musical theater i'm going to go to new
york let me exhaust that i want to be on
an original cast album i want to be
nominated for a tony and that's my goal
and so that's what i that's what i went
after
so so straight from school yeah yeah
straight from school i never think i can
stand out thank god i mean i never
i got cast right away in miss saigon
that summer so i nev i never waited
tables i never did any of that i'm so
lucky and did you have people were
casting directors saying things were
they kind of salivating about putting
you in movies do they want to capitalize
on your no no because because don't you
you know have you been new york based
the whole or no you were like yeah
started new york based and then
kind of moved into movies pretty quickly
right it was like i didn't i did it
happened it did i mean relatively
speaking it happened quickly but but my
limited experience with that cattle call
stuff is um
i mean it's it was a version of what i
remember my mom doing right now going
from one casting to the next and and uh
the closer of course you'd come to the
roll the nicer they would treat you but
but and did you ever do any of those
like because i don't i felt like i was
the only new york actor that never got a
law in order and never got any of that
stuff oh no i never did i um
i didn't no likewise yeah no i never did
i i i got into a tv show soon into it so
i i don't know i think um my situation
was a little yeah you you jumped the
line in a lot of you know a little bit
i can't believe you never did a law
order yeah no i mean because when mike
nichols saw me and i was doing the full
monty on broadway and so he brought me
in
to do to audition for um for angels one
of my um auditions out so i i
booked angels in america or maybe i'd
even shot it or something i was flying
out to la and la was pretty foreign to
me even though i'd done theater out
there but i went into an audition and
the cat and i opened my mouth and said
hey nice to meet you and patrick and she
goes i thought you were british and i
said why
i've said the story before but she she
said because you're 30 and i've never
heard of you and i was like
so then i got a little surly i was like
well i have been nominated for two tonys
i mean i'm not yeah it's two tonys
anthony's i know it's
isn't that crazy so so the big so
obviously then angels became
uh yeah yeah that must have opened a lot
of doors there oh yeah forever you're
working with al pacino and meryl streep
and all these people oh so you must be a
great actor regardless of whether i did
anything so then you'd get awesome
you've been anointed yeah no i was
literally like anointed i like i
remember getting the offer for hard
candy which might have been one of the
which you know i did in like
2000 but so hard candy became the first
i think probably first film that i was
offered without auditioning all of a
sudden this crazy dark little movie
comes to me and i was like wait you're
offering me this like what have i done
to show you that i can do this i mean i
could do it i love it but yeah yeah yeah
yeah why me i mean i remember when you
started those in
those the conjuring and the insidious
movies that you do right that is some
those are movies that i cannot i've seen
them and i i'm always tempted to watch
them when they come out but it is
they they freak me out so much and i'm
not even somebody who's like easily
disturbed by horror movies but those
movies um
because they're realistic enough and
they're
well acted you and vera are so good you
know that there's they're grounded in a
way that make them
so difficult for me to watch was that a
genre that you had
at all considered before was that
something that you were you a fan of
that genre no
yeah i mean well i i say that but if i
look if you gave me like i won't do a
top ten but if i thought of like a top
10 movies
i know in there i would have jaws i
would have silence of the lambs i might
even have the omen i might i like the
omen i'm for me it's probably not my top
ten but yeah like a overall like
including like great creatures and star
wars and all those i'm saying okay
so my point is
the movie has to elevate beyond the
genre which is something that i saw with
conjuring that i felt like oh this is a
movie that goes beyond the genre like
the exorcist like the omen totally like
any of those movies like when you even
when you look at the others those movies
that all of a sudden you're like yeah
this movie made 600 million dollars the
the
what lies beneath these movies that you
look at them and you're like
wait
that movie made and you and i bring up
money because you realize oh that's
different than just
trying to get the opening weekend 18 to
35 male horror crowd right so those kind
of movies interest me and i don't really
care
of the genre and then when i read
insidious i was halfway through
insidious and i was like wait this is
the guy that did saw like wait i got to
talk to this guy this is crazy not even
that's james james one i saw the first
saw and i was like that's intense and i
knew it started that whole
really
really
aggressive violent torture yeah uh
horror but i can as a person in the
business i can sit back and go but dude
you you you gave a shot of adrenaline to
that genre good on you and now he's
coming back yes right and then he's
coming back and it's and it's so well
directed you can tell when things are
regardless if it's you know your thing
cup of tea or whatever yes clearly right
right it's like what listen to music
that you're like this is not my cup of
tea but they're good at what they do
yeah yeah and so when i saw the the saw
team coming back to do this
but
there was no blood no language
pg-13
they moved from the house all this stuff
that was like oh they're pushing
themselves like that and that that got
me excited i said yes before i yeah i
got halfway through the script and i
called my agent i said this is this is
awesome i'm in
do you imagine yourself doing it and
imagine
uh
how easily it is to him to do that part
i mean is that how you kind of
come to the come to that decision do you
do you picture yourself two weeks in or
or does that does the dialogue itself
just like have no place in your mouth i
usually look for can i find my way in
with this guy like do i do you know do i
just do it do i get it do i get it
doesn't mean it'd be good or bad do i
care about him is it a story you want to
tell
because i had done several big movies
that had not performed well maybe like
your galaxy quest moment like
little children oh yeah little children
was i thought that was so successful it
was not at all because the subject
matter well i mean you know i a number
of things they never yeah
they ne from then i could be totally
wrong and i don't mind being wrong but
it was the year
really the
around the month that um the departed
came out and i remember
warner brothers like at the time
you know you really gotta double down on
what studio is gonna push forward in
terms of oscar
bait yeah so
i started to feel like because i kept
hearing oh they're gonna roll out the
movie or we're only opening in a hundred
so screens but then they're gonna roll
it out
i mean we got these love letters
of the best reviews and ao scots new
york times all this stuff that was just
like oh we're the movie and then
oh no kidding wow every time i would say
to someone or they'd say oh you're a
great little children i'd say where did
you watch it i watched it uh
at home screener or a dvd yeah you know
it was the 90s whatever you know 15
years ago so it didn't do well at all oh
that's interesting you know it's funny
because i saw it at at the arclight um
on i must have been opening weekends so
so
and i guess it was so limited that it
was i remember it being packed i
remember it being like it felt like an
event oh wow movie isn't that funny how
perception is can be so
interesting
so so to this day and i i guess i don't
really look at like you know i'm not
that up on like the numbers and stuff so
to this day i just always assumed that
it was this big my god it was a terrible
hit it didn't do it was critically you
know we got three oscar nominations out
of it and i yeah and i couldn't be
prouder of the movie but uh you know i
i've had as i'm sure we all have but but
you know i've had a couple
that and watchmen and movies that that
critically or you know i i know they'll
have legs with fans and in the business
and all that stuff but they just didn't
make any money yeah i mean that was a
even watchman yeah yeah but but even but
but little children only
i'll get the numbers wrong but they they
it didn't even make its budget back its
budget was it was expensive for an adult
drama i mean it was like yeah about a
pedera you know what i mean it's a
studio would not do a whatever it is 20
30 million dollar adult drama yeah yeah
uh moonfall the trailer's crazy uh it's
it's it really i was like it's a
disaster it's one of those disaster
movies what i've never been in one i've
always wondered how much
is it reacting are you on a green screen
for most of it just reacting
all the uh the stuff in space obviously
is all green screen the disastrous part
of shooting that i guess we had there's
a sequence in there where with the or
i'm in a hotel lobby and it gets flooded
you know we're i'm trying to save
john bradley and um
that i felt like oh right this is a
disaster movie like now i'm in it oh
okay
yeah
it just felt massive just you know
because you're having these
conversations and you're like and then
he's like and then the water will come
and then you're just looking this way
and i was like right and it's rolling
that's right right
i mean if you're gonna do a disaster
movie that's the game he's so naughty
and he's so not what like i've never
worked with like michael bay or anything
but i imagine
from what i've heard it's like i've
looked at joe carnahan and it's like
those really like yeah muscly fantastic
yeah and then and then roland's like i
don't know then you see this thing is
coming right at you it's it's a wave
it's crazy you know
and you're like right but like
what am i people running for their lives
and screaming it's literally that you're
like oh really but what am i what am i
looking at
lots of stuff just over there and i was
like right but i i need to know like
is it like a boat coming at me
yeah
i just i need something to do when you
say stuff
give me a hint is it a vehicle and then
you watch the movie you're like oh
that's what was coming at me okay i did
my reaction
i guess i pulled it off
yeah because so much was made in post
and we did they it's not they didn't
have their ideas roland is so specific
but yeah but when you're saying and then
you're inside the moon you're like right
that's not a real thing so
like i know frame of reference yeah for
that like if someone says to you you're
riding on a sea dragon you can kind of
go
all right i got my version of a sea
dragon
you know maybe maybe different than
yours but i bet the same species
maybe more of a children's illustration
that's okay
yeah
yeah he's friendly like the luck dragon
but then when you the thing about
moonfall that i think that i do think is
very interesting about that that roland
really wanted to push was this crazy
third act where it does get very like
like challenging
god and creation and
time travel and it's it's a lot it's
totally totally epic but it makes you go
oh i didn't think that was coming i
thought they're just gonna go like
armageddon go up into the and save the
oh that's cool so it that's good so so
so for all it's bombast and and epic
nature of the movie it it that that
third act that it is uh he's got such a
creative
mind um that it was um it was really
cool i mean it's very story heavy you're
like wait what like you did not so if
you're sitting there yeah popcorn you're
thinking like oh this is cool then all
of a sudden like come you know an hour
and a half in you're like oh oh i got to
really think now hang on what you know
yeah so you have to and are you
responsible for a lot of that story i
mean are you are you is that a lot of
that
yeah yeah that's that's yeah that's why
i wish i was on law and order
uh before so i got to train so i could
so i could move the west wing by the way
did you see what just happened what just
happened was this and that's what i just
saw you know yes yes
it's that about my i was i was just
talking to simon pegg yesterday and he
said um because he was he he does a
similar thing on star trek he's
responsible for a lot of exposition and
he said um he said you always know and
he wasn't saying about star trek but
when he had to write one of them he was
tasked with writing yeah i think star
trek brown but he he uh he said you
always know a bad script because he was
always tempted to write this way that
begins when a scene begins with so
you're telling me god i can't stand it
so what you're so what yeah so so what
you're telling me is
um bone tomahawk i keep wanting to talk
about
it
over your shoulder and yeah that keeps
coming up because i just worked with
vince vince vaughn who loves oh yeah
correct director
yeah he loves you yeah they've done a
couple of things to say about him
obviously i don't have a lot of movie
posters up but that for me that was i
mean it was a difficult experience for
sure but i mean a monstrously talented
guy
if there was any frustration about the
process and kurt russell and i have this
the same i i have to totally steal
kurt's line but at the last day of
shooting he turned to to me and to
zahler to the director he says well i
think we got about 85 percent of the
script and he kind of laughed and did
his progress like her car always laughs
with anything that's the thing about it
yeah right you know like he's gonna
laugh at the end of the line you know
like he just so
it makes it more it makes him well of
course
he's pissed at you
he's got you know like
it's it's more of an attitude kurt than
an actual
voice that's what it's really good
and he meant it in the way because
you're on such a tight budget such a
short shoot and the script was like we
fell in we loved that script so much so
any time it's the oh it's i'm telling
you it's one of the only scripts that
you're you're glued to every
direction everything it's not skipping
to the line you're you're not going to
dialogue you're like oh right and then
he takes the gun out and he slowly does
it and then he shoots him in and then
like oh and then he goes down his leg it
like and he dies and like wow last
breath escapes and you're watching it
and then of course
it's like we just need a gunshot and
you're like oh right because we don't
have time
so we were constantly yeah and here
you've got the director doing it so at
times we were so we were we were
frustrated that we couldn't shoot his
script you know yes oh that's usually
the opposite the opposite but so so so
any of our concerns and gripiness had
nothing to do with him because we're
still so proud of that movie it's just
every time someone says oh man that
movie's an a or you're like
i know and inside you're going you
could've been an eight-plus
yes yeah that's funny that's so great
but so yeah yeah how great have that
experience
[Music]
[Music]
patrick wilson what is your favorite
emoji your your go-to emoji favorite
emoji is the a tilted laughing guy
because i feel like i always need to
apologize in my text
i'm just kidding oh that's your apology
yeah
uh yeah well it's funny that's why i use
uh i use the uh
like
yes i do that one too yeah i see yeah
we're
cut from the same guilt-ridden block uh
who who who was your who was your first
celebrity crush uh alyssa milano oh yeah
it's funny she was on
this show talking about that her
experience with
guys coming up to her and being like i
gotta tell you something and she's like
yeah i know what you're going to say
yeah yeah because i didn't i mean there
was also like like heather thomas on the
fall guy right and there and there were
other people that were on tv
but she was
yeah like my age was seeing someone like
your age yeah right yeah
tv
you're like hey wait she's like 15. hang
on this could work yes
yeah and in your case it really could i
i um i i talked to uh alyssa alicia
silverstein yesterday and silverstone
yeah
um and who who i i was so
i would took everything in me to not say
because i was asking her the same
question and she said michael j fox and
i
and we were talking about her experience
with guys coming up and i remember
thinking
i didn't want to make her obviously you
don't want to say like well we heard a
crush on you but it's but i also felt
like well there was an innocence to it
enough um maybe i didn't feel it
innocent at the time so i
well i don't know how to verbalize it
what is your favorite ice cream flavor
graham central station at um applegate
farms here in uh montclair yeah it's
very specific right now okay
yes montclair i know pretty well i used
to shoot a show there um
graham central state that's it yeah
okay
some some caramel on top yep and that's
caramel okay yeah do you do you mind
when people call you pat i hate it i
hate it yeah okay oh good stuff but i
asked him
so patty you prefer patty patty's
totally fine oh patty's fine okay patty
people call me patty like close friends
will call me paddy it is weird if
someone calls you patty that like is not
like a friend like hey patty yeah
easy let me mister you
yeah like
like an insidious fan what what um is
does pat remind you of the character on
snl that yeah yeah i just i bet i wasn't
i just was never
i was never a pet i was never nobody
ever no because down south you know i
grew up i was born virginia north
carolina florida
pat was not big meaning yeah meaning
when i came to new york like it doesn't
grate on my nerves it's like like a
jersey guard in new york was like hey
pat can you just then i'm like
like that's their vernacular it's
weirdly okay and maybe this is
misogynistic but if a woman goes hi pat
you just i go yeah
it just i can't i can't
i know what you mean i just can't pat to
me was pat is like a
librarian whose kids are grown and
it's just pat i mean i have no problem
calling guys pat like there's a yeah my
sprinkler guy's name is pat i'm cool
with that like literally pat wilson is
the drummer for weezer and it's like he
goes
and like
that's cool never met him but i would
have no problem going yeah
i'm not a pat i just yeah
no offense
i'm glad i asked i'm actually really
glad i asked um so what you're saying is
so with the snl character you i can we
can say that patrick wilson does not
support the non-binary community
no no
no
uh what what is your favorite holiday uh
thanksgiving yeah yeah i imagine it's
great there yeah yeah thanksgiving is
who cooks who cooks the the
well it shifted i mean it's still to me
i still hold on to more memories that
are fewer and fewer of but 15 20 of us
in florida um and my aunt and my my mom
um those were the thanksgivings that to
me a lot of family getting together over
the years
um
years ago used to have a big golf
tournament it was like it was a it was
an event and then everybody did their
own christmases now yeah to be fair i've
missed so many thanksgivings working
because when you work in canada they're
like what canada does you know yes
yes we're thankful every day right
yeah um yeah
now we're sort of finding our own i
i do cook quite a bit but i don't i
haven't done a thing a thanksgiving i
usually
yeah so um this year my sister-in-law
veronica cooked so yeah we did it
in town uh the new mom
the new mom yeah yeah that's exciting um
what what's an acclaimed movie like a
you know one that people are
like kind of shame you for not having
seen one that you haven't seen that
you're kind of embarrassed to admit
oh that's good
um
yeah yeah it's and it's probably the
greatest movie ever and i've started it
and i'm this is going to really put me
in the crapper especially about to
direct my first film i will watch this
before i direct my first film um citizen
kane
oh yeah yeah you know what's funny that
yes i i think that is uh it's justin
oh yeah
we're we're talking about shame
it
is yeah yeah she's just talking from the
sidelines you said what yeah i hate that
there's not enough laughter there's not
enough laughter
really oh i thought there was
we're not serious okay well i thought
there was maybe too much
you heard me expanding before no i
should need to watch it back
sometimes we got serious we're talking
about yeah what's wrong with the guy's
two guys getting serious
oh i can't talk seriously about
you heard it here folks
this just did
patrick wilson shamed my wife for
talking seriously about new
movie wow
yeah citizens yes it's a citizen that is
a serious movie she's not going to like
you talking about this
because
it's a little serious
um uh what is your uh okay what what is
something that your wife might shame you
for
no i'm kidding um what is uh what what
is a game show
pastor present that you'd like to be a
contestant on
oh
let's see um double dare as a kid oh yes
i love dumbledore uh mark summers mark
summers yeah as yes yes um i don't know
if you saw the the snl with will forte
but there's a funny take off on that oh
is that um
if you have hulu uh oh he's great um why
do you drink to your coffee and if so
how do you take it coffee
uh
a coffee uh a lot of it um cinnamon
cayenne little oatmeal
huh
cayenne does that god that must really
get you going it's a little kick yeah
it's a little yeah
yeah yeah yeah why the cayenne just the
taste or the
yeah well i was cinnamon for for many
years
um because when i wanted to
so random who really cares i think it
was like yeah maybe like 10 years ago
i was i just would put a little sugar in
it and i was trying to go you know what
i can cut out sugar in my day but i
drink a lot of coffee so i'm just going
to start there that way if that makes
sense so that was something i could
control easier so then i just yeah and
then i was putting cinnamon on my coffee
and then i went home once and was
putting in my coffee and my aunt comes
up and she goes you know your
grandfather meeting her father he did
that his whole life and i was like oh
really
yeah wow how cool is it yeah so then i
just started putting cayenne in it
because i just wanted kind of the kick
and good for your heart and all that
kind of stuff oh it is it is okay i
wondered if there was a health um yes uh
if you could learn another language
patrick what would it be so easy uh uh
polish
yeah okay because you're a relative yeah
yeah and i get and i've spoken polish in
a movie and i've got like very remedial
polish that i can but i wish i could
speak it better
uh yeah i wish i could speak better
are dad's parents are they i mean
obviously fluent i don't know if they're
are they still
they're still alive yeah okay they
they're they're not together my
father-in-law lives in poland and uh
mom mom spends most of her time here
actually in the house since the pandemic
because she lives in the city uh and
also with the new babies she comes out
and helps out a lot but yeah no no they
they speak perfectly good english but
they moved here and they were like 30.
and so wow so she still they only
communicate in polish they only talk you
know so
i uh and and then we try to go to poland
a lot and i always um yeah i just want
to know what they're saying about you
too i imagine there is that but you know
what after like being married for like
16 years it's kind of nice to just kind
of zone out because i have to i can
understand a decent amount but i have to
like
sit there and follow it it's nice just
like you're a cat watching a ping-pong
game i have no idea
yeah yeah uh if you had to choose a
different first name we talked about
it's obviously packed
what would it be as a kid i always
wanted to be called kick
wilson kik that's a cool name yeah kick
wilson uh that's a great like old movie
star name uh kick old kick wilson like a
western actor that was the um slim
pickens and kick wilson dude
that's it yeah riding up riding up dirty
um if you
if you had a sec
if if you had a um if you had a sandwich
named after you the the patrick wilson
sandwich let's say it williamstown
there's a patrick wilshere what would be
on it what would you put on it sure um
uh oh man yeah cause it wouldn't
necessarily be my
my favorite sandwich used to be the neil
diamond at the carnegie daley which was
oh which is pastrami and corned beef on
rye but okay we're gonna go beyond that
because what do i eat more of what would
i do like like what would you how would
you want to be represented like probably
peanut butter
and banana
oh peanut butter and banana
um
or but see then i'd go a little honey
and it would sound like an elvis special
i'd probably go what my mother used to
make and
all my friends would make fun of me
which was and and and yeah i i can take
the judgment i haven't made one in years
but
she used to make me peanut butter and
raisins
huh
and i mean what type of bread just
whatever you know wheat bread but then
my friends are on the menu by the way
you're having peanut butter and
cockroaches because they just look like
these little black dudes fall out of
your out of your sandwich
uh this is yeah or palmetto bugs in
tampa this is true yes yeah yeah well i
no i would definitely not shame you for
that i would shame your friends for
comparing raisins
to cockroaches because they're
technically much smaller and um
you know
i used to love that we called them ants
on a log
yes raisins peanut yeah yeah so there
you go that's perfectly sensible it's a
it's a wild leap to go from the neil
diamond sandwich the pastrami and to
that but um
uh god i love kneel down uh what what is
your favorite tom hanks movie
oh this is a great question oh man i
should show you
[Music]
pause pause yeah great great i've talked
about this for
20 years i've never actually shown it
but i have it right over here oh
please oh yes i'm excited patrick is
leaving
uh frame
and he is back my favorite
okay my favorite tomix movie
i mean
i mean there's so there's so many um
yeah but i'm not gonna go with like
castaway or philadelphia or or some of
the big ones i'm gonna go
with bachelor party actually
yes
yes
i i have said this story before in a lot
of uh in interviews over the years but
i've never actually shown the photo
um yes i had this photo
so
um and you see this oh man he's holding
up
you know what we just try to put this on
instagram too
yeah hold on yeah this was the actual
photo oh sorry i gotta get this glare
but uh it's a photo of um there you go
that's
a photo of tom hanks arnold
schwarzenegger and a very long hair tom
cruise this is probably interview of the
vampire time this would have been gq man
of the year and my my roommate at the
time called roommate christian borel his
sister worked for her ritz the
photographer who shot him oh yes and
this was at the time when they would
have to be fair
yeah uh yeah vanity fair gq man of the
year i think it's gcu anyway it might
have been fair well who cares we'll
figure it out we could probably look it
up but there's a there's a there's a
little like
i don't know if you're photographing if
you're a photographer you would know
what it is but it made it kind of an
imperfect thing and he threw these away
this was the shot that he wasn't going
to use so oh wow what is it exactly
it's like a little hair almost
yeah it looks like something it's on tom
cruises
it looks like tom cruise has a um
has like a bocce
uh wicket in him like one of those
little like a yes staple
it does looks like a black staple in his
arm
so
she threw it away
and uh or sorry so so
i believe it's her ritz he throws it
away
my christian's sister who was working as
a like an intern for him or something
grabs it grabs this one and a couple
others and says it's being christian
she's like look i guess she's got these
photos they're not even out yet
christian keeps one i keep one i have
it's the only photo i've ever owned of
an actor actor is so funny and then i
meet him he was the first celebrity that
i met new york i'll um i'll go through
the story but you can see it online
you larry you google me and tom hanks
will probably find it he was the first
celebrity i met new york i just
graduated from carnegie mellon he just
won his second oscar he told me to
persevere
10 years 10 years later i'm doing full
monty um and uh and i found out he's
coming to the show and i tell the story
i was like you told me 10 years ago to
persevere i had this photo
i didn't end up seeing him that night
but like a week later his publicist
calls the publicist of the show and says
tom remembers that story
and he would love to sign the photo so
he writes to patrick who persevered
cut two that's cut
cut two several years later i'm doing
all my sons and with katie holmes
katie's married oh yeah tom cruise at
the time and i'm out with i'm out with
tom cruise and i'm telling cruz the
story i said you know we're talking
about celebrities or something i said
you know i have a photo of you and he
was like what and then i told him the
story about hanks and he goes i want to
sign it like i didn't even
because by the way i'm like 35 at this
point i'm not like a kid yeah yeah
and i was like i would i would love for
you to sign it so he says
tom cruises
so of course
of course he has to write more than tom
hanks uh patrick you did it
congratulations and thank you tom cruise
you're very sweet you really persevered
oh
no it's very sweet and then it's one of
my most prized possessions never shown
this before
after and he's famous for doing this tom
is hanks um after he saw fargo i get
this letter all right so he's patrick's
holding up a letter that said the
letterhead says hanks with an x
a-t-a-n-x yeah dear patrick by the time
you read this it's beautiful like a
typewriter written letter yeah well he's
got his tattoos right i may have
completed the season of far i just read
this i mean i have completed the season
fargo as of my typing i'm halfway
through the series is a mind resetter
making me wrap my head around ways of
telling story which is grand which is
equally grand as your performance you
are both proving your ability as an
actor and redefining all assumptions of
how good you are in other words you
continue to persevere and i am inspired
by your example all good things to you
tom hanks i am gonna
cry that is so that's why i moving that
he did that i could give
[ __ ] how movies of mine do when you get
messages like that from people that you
um that you just love my mom always
wanted me to be like him because he
he just did his thing he never knew
about anything behind the scenes and and
he was a great actually she used to say
because he's he seems nice and funny and
it was like a very oh my god sort of
just
be like that guy
totally you know patrick i if you have
to i got to tell you really quickly the
story after my um i have to you'll love
it uh um after like one of the first big
movies i did that the pa because i had
been with her she was the the base camp
pa i forget her name uh uh she
was really sweet and nice right i know i
know
18 years ago but she was um
she goes justin uh
you know you it was really funny fun
working with you are so nice whatever
it sounds like i'm complimenting myself
but she goes um
don't don't i hope if you become a big
star whatever you don't change because
if this movie does well whatever and and
i said oh thank you so much it's nice
and she goes yeah don't become like one
of these tom hanks characters
like these tom hanks guy and i said tom
hanks like i had only heard he was
the best and she goes oh no no no he is
you know not at all what you think and
and so i'm thinking oh [ __ ]
everything i've i've known about tommy
you know yeah and she's a she's like a
pa so she they see the real
right they see it all and so i thought
oh man i said well i assume she worked
with him and i said did you work with
them she said no
my friend and i
she wasn't even going to tell me this
she was going to leave it at that don't
be like tom hanks and she goes my my
friend and i were on the santa monica
promenade and uh we we saw tom hanks
with his wife and we we went up to him
and we said you know can we get an
autograph or picture whatever and he
under his breath
he he kind of rolled his eyes and he
said to his wife i told you we shouldn't
have come here
and
and that's that that was her story and i
said oh man well that's too bad but
immediately you know it's tommy's i
started like
trying to defend him and
looking at it reasonably and i said well
god santa monica promenade he must get
approached a lot and maybe he was having
a bad day you never know and she goes
and she as an afterthought she goes
yeah he was because um
my friend and i walked away and then he
he ran after us he ran up to us and he
profusely apologized and he said i'm
having a rough day and something
happened personally but i i'm so sorry
to take it out on you and i i'll be glad
to sign whatever and we took and i said
hold on
come hands
tom hanks ran after you i mean that the
the the humility that it takes to like
and the compassion and and then made up
for it by like taking photos and
apologizing you had a human moment and
she she wasn't going to tell me that
part and to me
that was the story that's what and and
it is the opposite of it i know i know
and
it always freaked me out patrick because
i was like oh man people and you see it
on the internet now more than ever it's
like people like to talk [ __ ] it's like
it's not a good story to just be like i
met this actor he was nice whatever
that's not as good as like he was a dick
and like
um so i think about that often but
that's crazy and you just confirm what
i've weird i know but but i love that
you have the letter i yeah and i i can't
wait to talk to you again and after
you've run into arnold schwarzenegger
and had a connection easier for him to
outdo the other two yeah he's guessing
oh sorry may i sign it um oh [ __ ] okay
uh we're almost done so that was so
great uh this stupid computer would you
really quick would you rather take a
time machine to the past or future yes
passed yes a particular era you want to
investigate um probably when
when my
family
came over
yes yeah you know i think it was like
in the 1600s like a
dis relative like wow just to see what
what that early wilson's yeah what that
like literally what that drive is to go
you left your homeland came across in a
boat like what do you what do you want
from this life you know yes yeah yeah um
are you more of a uh talker or texter
i've become more of a texter but it took
me a long time i was i was because now
i've got a friend that's a talker and i
can't stand it dude just text me
but i saw it but i still have two i step
my two closest friends my two best
friends yeah we are not we'll only text
us a couple back and forth and then we
call we still call oh that's great good
regularly yeah yeah important rare uh
night or morning person would you say uh
i would say morning now yeah yeah a lot
of all that coffee um pete would you
prefer i think i know this beach or
mountains that's a tough call i i don't
take i would take beach but i do love
the mountains yeah i do love the
mountains
i snowboard and um and i love and it
reminds me of my uh where my dad grew up
in the appalachians
yeah
do you have a preference toilet roll
over or under me look in the toilet roll
i think i'm probably i think i'm under
in this bathroom under okay and that's
not that conflict between you and dad
we're just glad if
if someone's replaced it i mean yeah
it's usually why isn't there any toilet
paper
that's true that's true who needs it if
you
yeah
if you would i got i got eddie
um
if you would finish this sentence life
is short so
spend time with your family yeah
yeah well please go do that and i'm
sorry i've kept you from them uh no man
thank you enough though this was so fun
awesome always fun to talk to you i feel
like i've known you forever even though
we haven't i know it's always a joke i
know i know look forward to like uh in
person hang yeah sounds good thanks
buddy thank you so much good luck with
the movie we'll talk all about it too
thank you
intro outro i appreciate it no problem
thanks
okay bye
so
that just happened so that just happened
oh yeah that's you're doing like um
handsome guys bruce wayne yeah i know no
he's uh no he's actually a little higher
than his wayne why was
why was he not batman that's a layup we
were talking about watchmen he's he was
a watchman but
why was he not a superhero another
superhero
no
i know he's got such a
he's perfect for it and such a good you
forget what a good actor he is because
it really is his uh hunkiness well he's
got that theater background too i know
and it's a rare combo
it's like why billy crudup uh well it's
a rare combo especially
i mean he was talking about back when he
was coming up you know being that kind
of guy like a real guys guy you know a
guy that
you know wanted to go to a college that
had fraternities and was into
sports yeah you know rock music and
who looked like that um to be that into
musical theater and so i think that was
i think it's more common now i mean
there's all sorts of people do all sorts
of things now more than ever yeah but i
think back in like he was saying back in
his day that was more of a rare thing
yeah well because when kids get
attracted to something um like that it's
it's usually in high school i think i
mean or before that but like high school
is the time where you start settling
into discovering your interest or
college certainly and um
and
it's there was a social component to i
don't know how to say this delicately
there was a social component to being in
theater
um as there was in football sports and
sure you know so there was usually a
type of i mean i i hate to stereotype
but it
everybody kind of knows at least when we
were growing up that there was a certain
type of kid who did theater and they
typically weren't like somebody like
patrick i mean patrick talk he talked a
lot about by the way i'm never going to
call him pat i think there are times
where i was like i've been
i don't know him that well i've been
like run into him but i've run into him
over the years and i i think there were
times when i called him pat he had a
very strong reaction to it sure did i
hate it
no he's such a positive person so it's
really you really like perk up when he
when he says uh but i always wondered
that about him because patrick to me is
so i've known other patricks but yeah
it's strikes me as such a formal more
formal he seems like such a cool laid
back i know kind of guy but but to his
in his uh defense pat
is padded it's a little ambiguous too
right yeah that's okay to say ambiguous
yeah
i i just mean it in so far as it's hard
to know what
gender you are yeah with that name there
are many female paths that's right for
male paths yeah so maybe it was a had to
do with that or i mean he kind of
alluded to that um but but but not that
that would bother him or should bother
him but pat pat also is like
it's also a verb there's something weird
about like yeah no maybe that's what it
is it's like a dab
or like what if dabo sweeney goes by dab
ever dabbo sweetie i didn't know who
that was for a second the coach yeah
i think it's dabo swinney oh it is i
don't know i think it's s-w-i-n-n-e-y
um but he might be sweeney he might be
right sorry but but anyway
yeah pat is like the thing of the act of
padding is kind of like condescending
and it's also kind of i can see it being
kind of a cutesy name and he is at your
laptop and he's such a
like a refined yes you know i don't know
he's clearly the son of a distinguished
uh anchor oh my god it could not have
been a kind of one who's like yes to
people like a benevolent
like the combination of of a voi like a
singer his mom a
chorus yeah
i know and a a news like i know a star
local newscaster father yeah of course
they made him you know produced that's
the perfect the best combination
also similar to our family
three sons
um yeah
not similar to our family yeah i can't
wait for this three sons who are the
dissimilarities
i mean looks aside
um
they had a they still do have a band
which i i didn't know about until i did
all the research they have like a cool i
know they rock bands they play cherry
they play it together for charity we had
a um
we had a piano trio yes that uh was you
know
kind of cool but it wasn't a rock band
it's a different definition of cool
yes it's that's that's a really generous
way of putting it yeah it's a different
it was definition i would say we were
more of the pat version
of the uh whereas they were the more of
a patrick musical group we were like the
past we were like the patty cake
yes it's true
pat pat we were the pet pet group and
they were the patrick yeah patrick is
very but uh i i i kind of gather what
was the name that he wanted to be that
uh
he wanted to be
but by the way i thought it was just
that um well while we're thinking of it
i thought of something that oh kik
dick wilson is awesome yeah cool name is
a cool name yeah and he could pull it
off you know who i'd like to be
is i was thinking about this because on
one of the episodes i was listening to
they asked me somebody jillian maybe
asked me and um
i liked i always thought this was a cool
name from a movie jacks
jacks was from um
keanu reeves played jax from feeling
minnesota
oh that was his name yeah i like that
movie yeah it's a cool it's a good movie
um yeah kick wheelchair jacks i just
think too much of uh the cheese yeah
cheese
treat snack
yeah maybe those are delicious those are
jacks and it's also you need to again
you need to be a certain kind of person
i think to pull a name like that off i
know you have to be keanu reeves or
patrick wilson yeah that'd be cool
yeah that's true not that you're not
cool jack's long but jack's long he's
really cool jax long also could be
jack's law a verb that you do for yes
yes yes that's true might be difficult
he's a good hang that was that's this
was a good episode he's a great hand one
of those episodes where i could tell
that you weren't
you didn't know him that well yeah but
you had a very easy rapport with him so
it felt like a like ketchup good hang
episode it was you know like max
greenfield kind of yeah yeah and he's
like an easy he's like kind of like the
friends i had growing up you know like
he reminds me of my friends from high
school like i would have been
uh hopefully it would have been
this arrogant to me to say but i bet he
would have he didn't he doesn't seem
like the kind of guy who had like
judgments about other people like who
was in what group and he just seems like
a very like like you said benevolent
about his very open-minded um he was
also in
theater he was like thriving in the new
york theater scene when it was you know
mostly i mean it was progressive it was
a progressive arena way before
um
you know
progressive uh
politics and and social issues came to
the
fore came to the like
social forefront you know he was like it
was it was mostly gay men like a lot of
gay men and and uh very it was just a
much more open
environment that he was in and he was
thriving and he strikes me as the kind
of guy who
had no
issue with it very accepting very
accepting yes he made a joke about
having 17 kids and for a split second i
was
weirdly hopeful that he did have 17 kids
yeah i know i thought how great for the
world how great for the world
spread those jeans man i know get it out
there i know i met people who i mean
forget his looks but i'm not going to
forget his looks including his looks
yeah but
in addition to his looks rather he um
he's such a kind person you know this
very altruistic more people like him i
know we want more people like him it's
very i think altruistic of you to want
that because
selfishly you could look at it this way
that more wilson's would dilute your
chances of um succeeding in the world
because you'd be less
impressive a whole true
it's funny how your brain works well it
didn't work like that i was just exam i
just thought well the flip side of that
is yeah i was thinking that's true but i
was thinking you'd be low or you'd fall
a couple pegs i was thinking
outside of myself more in that more
wilson's would cancel out more duggars
uh-huh yeah you know it's funny i was
thinking of the douglas too yeah i was
just in utah i'm sure look i'm sure a
lot of the strugglers are very kind
people but
some are very problematic and um
very problematic
beyond problematic yeah yeah it's that's
not even
yeah that's that's gone you guys
more wilson's more wilson's yes more
wilson's when when we were shooting lady
of the manor you couldn't go a couple
hours without hearing something about
that family i told him i know they're
they're everywhere i know i was gonna
say it's funny that he almost played
general sherman in our movie because
like oh if anything the only problem
with that would have been he's like a
little unrealistically good looking to
play civil war general general sherman
was he was probably kind of
not like that well he was pretty good
looking i mean he had like nice features
and and i remember thinking as you were
talking about that i i remember thinking
i hope
nick morgulis our
intrepid director of photography on that
movie is not listening because
uh
you said he's
not only did you say he's five foot
three and nothing against being a short
shorter person but now he's quite a bit
taller than five foot three yeah he's
exaggerating and he um and you said he
looks like a boy with a beard no and i
will say he has sort of like a manly oh
you think yeah he's little though i
don't know if we should be talking about
this is only nick maybe we should cut
all of it out cause like maybe what's
what's who's it gonna be funny to
us us that's it maybe that's true
whoever worked on the movie it's true
but but like it if you've seen the movie
you know you know it will also maybe
people who have seen the movie and maybe
you've thought
huh it looks like
that short person's standing on uh some
sort of
four apple boxes
stacked vertically
i laugh every time i see it but and it's
also part of the part of what makes it
so funny you're right is that
the alternative the
he he's filling in for
patrick wilson who would have been two
maybe two tall and too impressive yeah
on the other end of the spank this is
spanx
[Laughter]
what's the difference spanktrum
spanktrum or spenctrum spanked angdt
spanked like spank no spank or spanx
okay wow you don't hear the difference i
do now when you're hey
a schwa spank is it a schwa
no that's funny spanktrum spiff writing
slip other ends of the
when he said his first crush was
alyssa milano he said it very
definitively yeah i i thought
if he had made his intentions clear to
her at that time i know
he definitely would have gotten into a
relationship with her i thought
definitely but he would have had it well
you have to consider earlier i'm a good
shot yeah but a better shot much better
i don't know but who
uh
well who do you know i mean a list of
who's oh i'm trying well you know i'm
trying to think actually her husband 15
year old patrick wilson
yeah
like nice guy
from a great family
handsome well i was gonna say like you
don't know what her taste i mean that
might be like i i know some
beautiful i have a sense of what her
taste is well i do too now i was going
to say i was going to like agree with
you because dave her husband
is kind of a version of yeah wilson yeah
he's got like kind of jockey affable
charm and um yeah i i bet i bet that
patrick i bet teenage patrick wilson
would have had a good chance with
teenage alyssa milano
yeah and teenage alisa silverstone and
probably most most teenagers teenagers i
mean then yes yes not now oh
he doesn't want that no no he's got a
also patrick's got a beautiful funny she
came in his wife dag she's cool you'd
like her yeah she shamed you guys for
being too serious i know i know and he
uh they kind of tease each other like
that i've hung out with them before and
marika uh her sister is uh somebody i've
known for years oh actresses really oh
really yeah really good actresses and uh
polish
mom's gonna like that yes now why can't
you meet a polish a nice polish girl a
nice catholic polish girl who can make
you pierogies
you know
you know um oh i got hungry uh you know
what i was just thinking speaking of
being hungry um
uh and maybe we should cut this because
i don't want anyone to steal this idea
you're going to laugh when you hear the
idea um at the end of the year because i
was i was i've been listening i really
like have been latching on to their
sound people sandwiches some are like
really like inventive and interesting
but i thought it'd be cool to like at
the end of the year make all the
sandwiches a book oh a sandwich cookbook
with like a celebrity sandwich cookbook
like by the way if someone does
quote-unquote steal that idea
more power to them yeah that'd be cool
just to have don't you think
i mean for the show for the show yeah
what are we going to do with it sell it
yeah really should be cool to have it'd
be cool to have but it also means like a
coffee table book and that's what i'm
saying but it would maybe help like
promote the show too
i think that's a good idea yeah but i
also don't think we're gonna do it you
don't not really uh i think we should
think about it so can we do like a
verbal patent right now
yes i think you can okay really do i
know okay i pulled that out of my hand
we hereby claim the idea of making a
coffee table book or any kind of book
okay i'm am i being too specific maybe a
published
published work
of all the guests of this year who have
been on life is short with justin long
yes it's favorite sandwich yep okay
and we can at the end of the i mean
that'd be 50 something
sandwiches too
oh boy
um yes that tom hanks story is really
great and that it oh my amazing story
amazing um and your story's fine i've
heard that story before about about the
uh the pa the pa whose name you couldn't
remember i think it was on
anya um maybe you shouldn't remember
because it doesn't put don't clean her
in the best way that's true but i i
remember you telling me and it was even
more like
when
she first went up to tom hanks in santa
monica it was even less of a of a prop
like a negative reaction that he had was
it was even more subtle it was like
it was like a slight hesitation on his
part or like under his breath or like a
slight eye roll that's how she explained
it she said he did he didn't he didn't
know i was here but i heard it it was
like they had to touch him it was like
oh man i mean and
poor tom hangs
poor tommy is that crazy that these like
wackos think tom hanks is
we shouldn't talk about it no because
some people listening might think that
hey it's wild yeah it's a great story
it's a great just leave it at that yeah
and really like uplifting and i want to
do more you know it's such a good mark
to leave on
he's left such a good mark on the world
by doing things like that i mean it was
and that letter
was it so thoughtful thoughtful
and yeah man that's really cool i'm
excited for him to run into arnold
schwarzenegger yeah me too hopefully
future friend of the show tom hanks oh
how great we should get colin on yes i i
i should reach out to columbia not to
use him as a stepping stone to his
father
we should get rita wilson on to try to
bait her
on he didn't mean that but it would be
it might be a little bit easier for me
only because no i understand i don't
know tom
you know one of the funny ones oh tommy
tommy
tommy
tommy what if he prefers tom there's
there is instead of thomas hanks that's
what jonah that was one of the funniest
things joan used to do
before he himself became tom hanks level
famous
he would check into hotels under the
name thomas hanks i hope he doesn't
still do that
and you just blew his cover i don't
think so i don't know i hope not but um
it was funny thomas and and he said he'd
always registered disappointment when
he'd show up and they were like
miss oh mr hanks and he'd be like yep
that's me thomas hanks
tom you call me tom but it's thomas
hanks uh let's read a little yes okay
crinkle crinkle from alex gorad
goranitsky
gorad nitsky subject what about justin
dear justin and christian hope my email
finds you well greetings from wintry new
york city my name is alex and i'm a
cardiologist cool in parentheses for us
thanks alex he says heart doctor
thank you alex
in west village
life is short help me navigate less
glamorous aspects of being a doctor that
they don't cover in tv shows with long
brothers cheering me on mountains of
digital paperwork seem less daunting and
can actually be kind of fun
that's really nice it's nice to imagine
that we are like accompanying people
while they're doing because i i hate
doing this i've been listening to
podcasts too when i'm doing like
and not not that road trips are road
trips can be quite
boring and
you know um depends where you are it
depends yeah and who you're with that is
true um
it's also nice to know that someone
a cardiologist i know he's listening a
cardiologist in the west village cool
in your rob rigo episode you mentioned a
great 90s flick what about bob i was a
little young when the movie premiered
wow but i remember watching it in the
early 2000s when i was in school bill
murray and richard dreyfuss were
absolutely phenomenal i'm surprised that
they didn't make more movies together
interestingly i rewatched what about bob
recently and had a somewhat different
perspective on it i run into patients in
the neighborhood from time to time it
can be a pleasant and yet awkward
experience the idea of a patient
following me on vacation seemed somewhat
terrifying i still enjoyed the movie but
it was a different impression from the
earlier one because of my training and
current job did you ever have an
experience of re-watching a classic
movie you loved earlier in life and
seeing it differently from a slightly
older and more mature perspective what a
great question and what a great point um
yes i really i recently had the the
experience of watching misery again
uh after having
been had
kind of tangential experiences with
again this is the second brag of the
of the show um
with the story you told on dax's podcast
yes
since that happened to me and there are
other things that like you know it's
certainly on social media that can be
kind of scary people
you know scary people reaching out and
um
and so i've had a different experience
with that movie i had a different
experience watching it uh it was
actually more there were there were more
subtle moments of of terror and it it
play it it tapped into um
it more often tapped into a primal fear
that i that i now that has been stoked
by
years of um being a somewhat known
person that makes sense um but what a
great question and he says i'm not a
great is back to alex i'm not a gr i'm
not great at would you rather questions
but we'll give it a try would you rather
become a better person by reliving the
same day like bill murray and groundhog
day weird
or have series of ghosts visiting you
like bill murray and scrooged oh man you
know i've never seen scrooged but i
should i should see scrooge a long time
ago i saw it i don't know it well at all
no but having never seen it i would
i mean as much as i want to be a better
person i would 100
pick ghosts um popping up than reliving
the same day oh really oh my god that
groundhog day is it's a great movie
obviously and it's so funny and
i would rather and poignant but but it's
like
by day 10 i think i would lose my mind
well i this is a question i have for
alex is in his question is it does it
assume that like bill murray and
groundhog day once you become a better
once you realize the meaning of oh yeah
that's a good question
will you then you know um but who's to
say how long that'll take
well you just make sure you do it fast
no i don't know i i wouldn't mind being
in a loop like that because
you get to first of all
just on a very like hedonistic level
you get to like
do some fun things like eat whatever you
want fine fine you know fine
a year on a loop
try 20 years on a loop
try oh no no no no no nightmare i know
it's nice in us in doses well i'd like
to think that i'm closer to i'd like to
think i'm closer to being a better
person than bill murray was in the
beginning of groundhog day so i wouldn't
have as far to go okay but again you're
assuming that there is an end in sight
okay there'd have to be because
otherwise it's serious it goes what is
that is you're constantly having ghosts
visit you sure uh i would definitely i
would still take that you get used to it
you get used to those and you'd learn i
mean talk about being a better person
what if they're what if they're still it
would i'm assuming they're benevolent no
i'm not assuming i'm assuming all sorts
of ghosts are possible in this scenario
but even the but even the malevolent
ones yeah uh i feel like i could get
used to it to some degree and maybe
learn something it's gonna be like a
living nightmare i mean think about when
you're like i see i think a bigger
living nightmare is read living the same
day over to me that's a living nightmare
until yeah i guess forever for oh
forever yeah yeah well well why would it
be that
different than you could go places in
that day i always thought that about
what about bob he's he's stuck in
punxsutawney
um he's stuck there but he could
technically
right does he try to leave the city at
any point i think implied in the
question is you're doing the same thing
every day like you're in a hamster wheel
i think that's implied you can't go to
iceland or uh you know madrid and enjoy
yourself and meet new people who are
experiencing the same day over and over
again you're stuck in this implied
you're stuck in the same spot i guess i
take the ghost too
until you become yeah i guess you get
used to the malevolent ones i mean think
about it like once you've dealt with one
malevolent one like
like
for some [ __ ]
and it's like how much scarier could
exactly
you'd probably develop a really thick
skin yeah that's true and then you'd
have so much bravery going through the
world you would never get scared of
everyday things and you know what you
could do is like you could start
investigating why the ghost those like
angry mean like terrifying ghosts are so
like what their pain is i think you
could become a ghost psychiatrist i
think once you got over the
sheer fear of it all i think it would
enhance your life a lot if that was
happening to you is that what that
jennifer love hewitt shows about the
ghost whisperer wasn't that a show
does she like talk with ghosts and like
help them like transition i never saw it
so i don't know anywho back to you alex
and he's what he says yes
and by the way that's a great wish you
rather it's great yeah don't i i had a
feeling it would be now i want to see
scrooge
to see how uh yes
been a hippo yeah benevolent they are uh
anywho if you find yourself back in the
city and need a broken heart mended you
are welcome to visit oh man i it's
actually good to know it's great to know
if i'm having like
you know
palpitations
palpitations uh best wishes alex goradic
p.s i'm sure that you get a lot of these
notes if by chance you do decide to read
this one i would imagine my last name
might present a challenge it is
pronounced exactly as it is written go
rad go rod
justin and i are the same age he can
totally play me in my biopic if you can
pronounce the name like justin i also
really want to visit machu picchu but
life and bathroom situation seem to be
getting in the way well alex uh i did
look into this the machu picchu
situation machu picchu and um
and there is one and he's a cardiologist
so i'm sure he can afford this one it is
uh there's kind of like a fancier one
where
they the bathroom's situation is a
little bit easier to handle
oh really yeah they i forget what it is
but like they kind of like bring a thing
along with them i mean it's still a
little
gnarly but
you know i'm surprised that alex has
that issue because he's a well
cardiologist but he must he's not a
proctologist yes
that's true
any well thank you for your letter what
a great great letter to know what
cardiologist and if you guys would like
to write in our email address is life is
short at wundery.com
thanks to our guest patrick wilson and
check out his movie that's out now moon
fall moon fall yeah it looks really fun
yeah yeah and uh and to all the wilson's
down there in tampa yeah shout out shout
out to the wilson's um you know i think
he spoke we spoke with his mother i
think you did i did yeah yeah she's so
nice such nice people obviously i mean
look at him um so thanks patrick and
check out uh all of his great work i
want to go back and watch angels in
america oh that's amazing yeah um i love
that mini series um great guy uh great
actor and uh
great episode
and now friend of the show end of the
show yeah it's good to have him on our
roster
yes yeah so thanks to everyone who
listened and uh made and other friends
listeners of the show shorties
bye we'll see you next week talk to you
bye
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
longing is co-hosted and co-produced by
you christian long also produced by
megan d monaco and katie fee allen
senior producers michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez the
surge
and executive producer marshall louis
for wondering
good bye
watch men and people and watch ladies
and watch people
[Music]
what's the opposite of blessing in
disguise as it relates to as it relates
to right um
we thought i had thrown a dessert out
in claire's and a bag of desserts i
thought i thought strawberry short game
it doesn't matter whatever something's
positive
good and it turns out it was in the
fridge all along
so we said well
it that's
yeah
but we didn't really want it because it
was bad and the long run bad for you and
yeah
yeah and then i think so what's the
opposite of blessing in disguise
based on that okay
you